jeannette nous voulons que le jury vous
soutiennent mais vous êtes loin de
donner l'impression que c'est vous la
partie lisais je suis la fille la plus
détestée du pays
tant que vous voulez que je lui
ressemble plus c'est ça
jamais tu as c'est ça ouais c'est mon
anniversaire joyeux anniversaire
on veut tous qu'on ne peut pas avoir
même si on doit changer pour l'obtenir
je crois qu'un jour je serai une jolie
fille populaire ici ce que tu veux il ya
des moments dans la vie qui m'ont change
pour toujours
kate wallis a disparu depuis maintenant
quatre jours
[Musique]
la dernière chose au monde dans cette
ville de merde avait besoin c'était une
autre quête wells
c'est sûr tu n'es pas mort je suis
vraiment accro
tu penses toujours à quel taux
non
je crois qu'elle a vu les c'est soit ça
soit c'est l'autre solution
jeannette lève toi ton avocate et là
quelle importance
est ce que tu crois que rien ne sera
jamais plus comme avant pour être
honnête je n'arrive même plus à me
souvenir comment c'était
tu l'as vu non bien sûr que tu sais que
jamais je te mentirais
jeannette stoner est humain la média
radio et d'un coup du jour au lendemain
il est devenu et notre ferme
ce qui est arrivé à cette fille est une
tragédie mais ce qui t'arrive à toi je
ne peux même pas vous
[Musique]
j'ai personnes qui me soutient j'ai pour
rien être mais pas celle que vous croyez
tu viens de dire quoi là le mali est
parmi nous juste sous nos yeux
[Musique]